erina whose is a counselor and career
advisor she uses social networks a lot
for work and has over a thousand
Facebook friends one day many of them
started getting strange messages
supposedly sent by her if I'm a hooked
ich eine SMS not I suddenly got a
barrage of text messages and calls and
didn't know what had happened given you
can then a girlfriend told me she got a
really weird message that was supposedly
from me on Facebook it wasn't me Erna
switched on her computer and saw right
away that her entire facebook account
had been duplicated using this new
account the so-called face crooks had
set out new friend requests often along
with a personal message those who
replied then received a second message
from the fake erina who's asking for a
loan of 500 euros she promised to pay it
back the next day plus an extra 50 year
olds the other good advice anyone who
knows me knows I would never do a thing
like that but I have over a thousand
friends so I was in a total panic pushed
computer expert York she explains how
the scam works the face crooks
duplicated hair in his profile using her
photo and her name then they targeted
her friends
that is not read his bio scan takes
advantage of a social community and
almost everyone falls for it no one's
going to start making sure they run
regular checks on whether the facebook
profiles they're looking at a genuine or
not when he's died in the fire agate
opted Erina doesn't actually know all
her facebook friends personally she
mainly uses her account for work users
like her make it easy for scammers her
lacks privacy settings make copying her
account of the piece of cake Facebook
CEO Mark Zuckerberg has pledged to clamp
down on fake accounts but users also
need to do their part the things or the
communities of users need to hide their
friends lists you do that by tightening
your privacy settings you can let people
see who you're friends with or you can
ensure only your friends can see this
information anymore after the fan site
its design their new hose has now hidden
her friends list she's not as casual
about Facebook as she used to be
fortunately none of her friends
transferred money to the scammers
shift says beware of false friends